bonjour edmond placide oui bonjour à
vous et sea hawk aux attitudes de marne
et combien vous êtes le président de la
sa fille la société d'accompagnement et
de financement des entreprises
une société sous forme de coopérative
alors ce matin on va essayer de faire
dans l'information pratique à
l'intention des entrepreneurs des
entrepreneurs qui ont déjà des
entreprises développer ou des personnes
qui veulent se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat sur un credo que vous
avez à la safi c'est que certes il ya
des difficultés à se faire financer mais
qu'il faut surtout un bon dossier avoir
constitué un bon dossier pour convaincre
et persuader les banques et autres
organismes de crédit de finances est
justement une entreprise tout à fait
l'enjeu est là d'un jeu c'est de
présenter un dossier et en sachant que
la relation avec la banque propose sur
deux pays essentiel c'est la crédibilité
et la confiance la codi bilité passe par
un dossier qui répond à une
préoccupation que nous savons c'est à
dire est ce que votre dossier est
réaliste et réalisable et tout notre
métier consiste justement à le rendre
réaliste et réalisable alors vous dites
que c'est pas tant les banques qui sont
frileuses même si ça peut arriver
enfin que voilà quoiqu'une qu'une banque
si elle a peint un dossier bien ficelé
pour aller vite
ben peut pas peut pas soutenir deux
choses lorsque le système financier
remarqué que historiquement est
structurellement dédiée aux particuliers
ces caractéristiques à l'intérieur vous
avez effectivement des financements
d'entreprises qui est qui augmente au
fil des années et il est évident que si
un dossier présenté correctement
banquier il ya de très fortes chances
qu'il soit accepté donc l'idée pour nous
et ça a été notre que des manches en
direction des élus que donc comprise et
acceptée aussi c'est de mettre en place
le tri 3 une démarche pédagogique et
sans cela que notre notre action est
différente et les particulière parce
qu'elle exige vis-à-vis de qui des
professeurs de l'interface soit plus
porteurs de projets ainsi qu'aux
entreprises qui sont déjà existantes
c'est leur dire que dossier loi répond à
des critères pour que le banquier et il
faut qu'ils comprennent donc que ces
critères sont indispensables le banquier
a une approche
l'idée c'est ce n'est pas une approche
comme des la puissance publique est là
dedans il faut donc répondre à des
critères qui sont très précis très clair
c'est à dire on peut décliner sa ainsi
il faudrait qu'il y ait une adéquation
entre l'homme et son projet il faut que
le projet économique et financier il ya
un équilibre
il faut que les choses soient objectives
sera précise mais il faut surtout aussi
soigné des questions de forme y compris
la rédaction de votre projet lorsqu'un
projet qui est mal rédigée c'est un
projet qui va intéresser l'autre à le
découvrir
nous apportons tous ces éléments alors
si vous voulez pour schématiser si vous
êtes dans une configuration vous faites
une demande de financement
vous avez une réponse binaire oui non si
la réponse est oui
lorsque dossier bascule son cours
normalement si elle est non et que si
c'est des réponses négatives que navx et
que vous n'avez pas l'explication le
poids du non vous vous retrouvez
effectivement démunis et le papa
forcément acceptant la décision à la
safi le nom peut exister mais c'est un
nom qui peut être qualifié et c'est là
l'essence alors eu tellement de façons
on va y revenir sur la requalification
de la demande de financement de crédit
mais d'abord vous adresser
prioritairement a acquis qui a besoin de
ce type d'accompagnement ici en
martinique on imagine que c'est pas les
grands groupes les grosses entreprises
mais peut-être les tpe les auto
entrepreneurs certains noms je pas
d'artisans voilà notamment vous voudrez
à travers un fonds garanti de
microprojets c'est ça vous accompagner
aussi les souks désigne par micro
projets il faut nous mettre en
perspective la typologie des entreprises
martiniquaises à 95% ce sont des petites
structures
donc le gros le gros dit tu suives des
entreprises étaient intéressées
concernés directement par notre
intervention
voilà donc et pour cela effectivement
nous avons considéré que pour exercer
ses missions que la collectivité de la
demande et nous a donné parce qu'en fait
vous remettiez retenus à l'issue d'une
consultation pour mettre en oeuvre
ce qu'on appelle le dispositif
d'accompagnement financier qui est
cofinancé par la ctm chose que vous êtes
en partenaires de la collectivité
territoriale au sens unique l'ensemble
nous sommes en fait le le
l'interlocuteur le prestataire qui a été
retenue par la collectivité pour mettre
en oeuvre son action pour faciliter
l'accès au crédit bancaire des
entreprises
c'est le seul qui sera alors ce sens
nous sommes donc cet opérateur et la
proche est particulière alors pour cela
nous exerçons si vous voulez plusieurs
métiers oui si vous voulez en plomb mais
non je le public qui est le plus visé on
vous avait commencé mais il est là c'est
l'essentiel du tissu c'est à dire de la
petite entreprise à plus petit jusqu'à
l'entreprise ontarienne qui a parce que
nous n'avons pas de plafond en matière
de financement bancaire d'accord
lauriane donc une espèce dans votre
travail de d'accompagnement de soutien
vous faites une analyse du risque aussi
un vous vous aider l'entrepreneur
c'est important aussi vis-à-vis des des
financeurs et c'est là peut-être
effectivement que peut intervenir aussi
ce travail de requalification de la
demande après un ou deux refuges
temporaires dans votre esprit justement
de la part des banques voyage à nice 2-2
de nom définitif en quelque sorte
alors ça c'est arrivé mon fameux oui
alors c'est justement là qu'intervient
ce que des marchés là vous touchez un
point essentiel si plusieurs banques
s'exprime négativement sur un dossier
sur un projet il faut considérer le
projet pose pour l'un et souvent les
porteurs de projets jeunes entreprises
ont du mal à intégrer
et lorsqu'ils viennent nous voir ils ne
comprennent pas forcément pourquoi il
entend de temps de correction à apporter
le dossier parfois ça me va être vous
parlez vous parler de mon placide de
rendre les projets réalistes et
réalisables
tout à fait c'est extrêmement important
là est l'enjeu parce qu'apparemment nous
avons des projets qui ne sont pas
réalistes ils ne sont pas aussi
réalisables et ça passe par la
pertinence du projet sont une
opportunité
les chiffres qui sont présentés la
cohérence globale du projet donc tout
ceci adaptation à la réalité locale des
fois qu'une spécificité devant la passe
corman nous recevons des dossiers déjà
constitués qui dans la foulée tact dans
leur forme initiale
c'est aussi ne peuvent pas être financés
pour le moc et donc ses secrets
faisant comprendre à ces chefs
d'entreprise les accepte c'est parce que
certains avec nous ont eu du succès pour
accéder au crédit bancaire et ce qu'ils
ont puis ce succès témoigne de la grande
efficacité
c'est un projet pédagogique qui est
nouvelle sur le territoire et elle elle
interroge en réalité l'élu dans sa
démarche politique
est ce que je peux dire non c'est qu un
citoyen qui viennent devant tant que
politique c'est un peu cette démarche
conceptuelle que nous avons aussi à la
safi proposé aux élus c'est que vous
pouvez pas dire oui donner des
subventions par marc fonds perdus ne
règle pas le problème
pour nous c'est l'accès au crédit
bancaire qui va rendre l'activité pyrène
et dans la subvention est rappelé à tout
à chacun ici que la subvention ne fait
pas le prêt et qu'il faut au préalable
que le dossier soit finançable par le
banquier est allé à ce moment là je dis
oui en fait récupéré la cerise sur le
gâteau qu'est la subvention bon parlons
de l'état d'esprit un peu dans lequel
tout ça est fait il s'agit d'une forme
de finances solidaires aussi puisqu'on
est on est haut dans le domaine de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
le tas fait alors historique mal à sa
fille s'appelait la coga elle a été
créée en décembre 1972 long coopérative
une coopérative à l'époque rouillé par
notre pays fondateurs non monique
illustre si monsieur stéphane pezerat
qui n'est plus de ce monde
donc il serait ce que je veux de savoir
jusqu'où nous avons pu mener son projet
initial
c'est lui aussi qui a créé le crédit
artisanale donc à l'époque
l'accès au crédit bancaire se posa
autant d'acuité que maintenant et c'est
ses hantises ans ont mis ensemble des
moyens financiers et ont rapporté une
solution collective
à l'époque la cobac garantissait et
nombre de martiniquais ont pu accéder au
crédit bancaire grâce à l'action de la
commune a donc nous continuons l'oeuvre
de monsieur badra aujourd'hui nous
allons nous avons étoffé
nos réponses parce que depuis le début
de l'année sont devenus ce qu'on appelle
le mandataire exclusif de talisman
financier
ben c'est sûr france métropolitaine et à
ce titre nous distribuons son offre de
services qui est composé des
professionnels et nous avons donc
financer ses voeux de bonne année
plusieurs entreprises au niveau local
alors il nous reste une minute
dans une interview non placide il ya
quand même quelques il ya des critères
pour donc retenir les entreprises qui
avec lesquels vous pouvez travailler
vous faites attention à ce que ce soit
des projets d'utilité sociale qui est un
critère de responsabilité
environnementale et sociétale
enfin voila vous ce sont des écrits
texte commun important pour nous parce
qu'on ne peut plus continuer à financer
vos exercices ou territoires sans se
soucier de l'impact sociétal et
environnemental dans son activité
donc si vous me permettez c'est dire aux
intéressés de se rapprocher d'un coup de
nous soit par notre site internet
c'est sa fille point fr s afp ou encore
au 05 96 50 33 95 toute dernière
question et puis si vraiment à la fin
des fins ça ne marche pas quoi comme
comment ça se passe où est ce que ça
donnait un ca arrive ça arrive à une
garantie deuxième caractéristique
essentielle chez nous c'est que le
dossier ne sortira pas de chez nous s'il
n'est pas finançable et nous nous
réservons donc l'initiative des terreaux
le processus si nous considérons que le
dossier n'est pas réaliste et réalisable
parce que nous sommes nous aussi
maintenant de la distribution du
financement
on ne peut pas se permettre de donner un
dossier important de projets en tranches
une entreprise alors que nous savons à
la base qui n'est pas non que finançable
voilà dix ans très bien merci merci
elles m'ont placide président de la sa
fille d'avoir répondu à nos questions
dans sa au caddie en ce mercredi merci
merci
c'était ça au caddie avec bertrand car
hulk on retrouve demain à ses terres 18
dans mon matin première ce matin
pardon avec daniel marie-fitzbach est
déjà à porte parole du conseil exécutif
de la ctc sera annoncé que la ville
était aux mains baladeuses 5 à 10